If you want to know about why Mike was the
one to stay back in Derry while his friends
moved on without him, then stick around to
the end of this video.
This lesson is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
Visit expressvpn.com/czsworld to learn how
you can get 3 free months.
Welcome to Horror History.
"Who'd want a history of this toilet?"
My name is Abraham Lincoln: Taco Hunter and
this time I’m not the only Horror Hist…
orian of the episode because I’m covering
Mike Hanlon.
Mike was the seventh and final piece of the
Losers Club -- a researcher who used his knowledge
to help guide his friends in the right direction
to be able to understand and take down their
supernatural rival.
To understand why Mike became interested in
cataloguing the history of Derry, we’ll
have to dig into some history texts as well,
starting with Mike’s earliest days of infancy.
[HORROR HISTORY]
Michael Hanlon became the only child of William
and Jessica Hanlon in 1946 and was born into
a life of farming.
One day, when Mike was only a baby, the weather
outside was nice, so Jessica took her sons
crib outside so they could enjoy some sunshine,
where baby Mike was attacked by a wild bird,
which pecked at him until his mother shooed
it away.
This trauma somehow stuck with Mike into his
older years, where he would continue to have
a fear of birds.
He grew up helping his father man the farm,
which he was paid for, and received a 5% stake
in the business in order for Will to teach
him the value of hard work.
The work consisted of picking peas, radishes,
beans, potatoes, pumpkins and squash.
In 1951, Mike began school at the Neibolt
Church Street School, a religious institution
that kept him from meeting many of the kids
his age in town who attended Derry Elementary,
leaving him to fill the time his father gave
him off of work in the summers by himself.
The Hanlons sometimes had trouble with their
racist neighbor, Butch Bowers, and not long
before the Spring of 1958, Butch’s son Henry
joined in on the torment when he killed the
Hanlons’ dog Mr. Chips by feeding him a
poisoned burger.
It was at this point when Will felt it necessary
to teach his son about some of the evil people
that inhabit Derry, explaining that Butch
was crazy and that he should stay away from
Henry.
He goes onto explain some of the inexplicable
acts of racism throughout Derry’s history.
Will was somewhat of an amateur historian
himself, and kept a photo album that documented
certain events from Derry’s past.
He used this to teach his son how stay on
guard, and I think sparked Mike’s interest
in studying the past.
Mike also learned how to drive the tractor
from his father and each year they would do
a rock harvest.
Although Mike enjoyed playing in the snow
during the winter, he always felt a sadness
when the harvest season came to an end.
Will instilled a strong sense of morality
into his son by giving him small tasks to
teach him life lessons, or take him on day
trips, like when he took his son to the police
station to see the Tramp Chair, a restraining
device used earlier in the century to punish
wrongdoers.
One day, Mike discovers a note from his father
telling him to go check out the remains of
the old Ironworks that exploded in 1906, an
activity meant to clue Mike in on violent
patterns of Derry’s past.
This was only one day after he had watched
the movie Rodan with his dad, and when he
arrived at the ruins, he discovered a giant
bird hiding in the cellar hole.
Mike ran, and the bird swooped in to try to
pick him up, so he took refuge in the smoke
stack.
The bird tried to squeeze into the enclosure
with him, and Mike was only able to drive
it away by throwing pieces of tile, and getting
some assistance from some unknown force helping
him throw harder, likely It’s rival the
Turtle.
One of the pieces of tile pierces the bird
and it disappears.
When Mike gets home, his father regrets telling
him to go over there without Mike even having
shared what had happened.
I think Will is somewhat privy to the effects
of It that haunt Derry and senses the Ironworks
could be dangerous, even if he wasn't aware of the monster itself in the same way
Mike is.
A couple months later in June, on the first
day of summer vacation, Mike went over to
Bassey Park near the canal and smelled a salty
old sea smell in the morning fog that gave
him a sense of danger.
He discovered a pocket knife with the initials
E.C. in the grass, and was going to take it
for himself until he saw blood.
This makes him think of the bird from the
Ironworks, but he pushes the thought away.
He follows a set of grooves in the grass,
and they lead him to a bloody piece of cloth
and dried blood at the canal’s edge.
He sees something move in the outflow tunnel,
then hears a loud splash that causes him to
throw the knife into the canal and run to
his bike, but he could hear wet footsteps
following him in the grass.
He would later hear of the disappearance of
a boy named Edward Corcoran, most likely connected
to the blade he found with the letters E.C.
Mike was the biggest target of the town’s
most prominent bully Henry Bowers.
Well I guess Ben was technically the biggest
target, but Mike was Henry’s favorite target
because of the rivalry between their fathers.
In July of 1958, Henry and his gang were targeting
Mike on a regular basis.
On July 3rd, they chased after him while he
was on his way to a marching band rehearsal.
Mike played the trombone, and this would be
the last rehearsal before their Independence
Day performance.
The bullies chase him down to the abandoned
property at 29 Neibolt Street and Henry reveals
that he was the one that killed Mike’s dog,
causing Mike to snap and throw at rock at
Henry’s forehead, causing it to bleed.
He climbs over the fence to escape, but Henry
catches his shoe as he does, so Mike kicks
down and breaks Henry’s nose.
The chase continues to the gravel pit in the
Barrens, where Mike fortunately runs into
Bill Denbrough, Ben Hanscom, Beverly Marsh,
Eddie Kaspbrak, Richie Tozier and Stan Uris.
An epic rock fight ensues, and the kids are
able to drive away Henry’s gang.
“I think the six of us can put you in the
hospital.”
“Seven.”
That was the moment that Mike Hanlon joined
the Losers Club, a name given to them by Henry
Bowers himself.
Mike could relate to these kids, because just
like he is bullied by Henry for his skin color,
each of them have something about them that
caused Henry and his gang to go after them.
Bill had his stutter, Eddie his asthma, Ben
his weight, Beverly her scandalous reputation,
Richie his glasses, and Stan his Torah.
The group got to know Mike, but they would
not bring up their encounters with Pennywise
just yet, and although the movies don’t
cover it, the next day Mike would have his
first encounter with It in its favorite form.
One of Mike Hanlon’s greatest strengths
was his ability to document everything that
occurred in Derry to use against Pennywise.
Now when I’m surfing the web, I don’t
want someone like Mike documenting my activities
online and using them against me.
That’s why I recommend ExpressVPN.
A VPN is a virtual private network.
If you’re connected to an unencrypted internet
network without a VPN, you’re putting yourself
in danger.
Any hacker on the same network can steal your
login details, credit card numbers, really
any information you send over that network.
Don’t go out much?
You still need a VPN.
In 2018, the FCC’s new rules reversed Net
Neutrality, so these internet service providers
who are at least 10x more evil than Pennywise,
can now sell all your data to the highest
bidder.
But not if you have ExpressVPN, ExpressVPN
encrypts all of your data and reroutes your
connection to one of their servers so that
your ISP and hackers can't see what you're
doing.
Let me show you how to set it up.
*click*
That's it.
It also allows you to watch your favorite
horror movies that might not be available
in your country.
For example, I can't watch this movie in my country,
so ExpressVPN is gonna tell the website that I'm in a different country.
And now I can watch it.
So take back your Internet privacy TODAY because
I’m giving you 3 months *FREE* by clicking
the link in the description box, that’s
expressvpn.com/czsworld.
Take back your privacy today with EXPRESS
VPN!
Ahh, July 4th.
American Independence Day.
A day for barbeques, fireworks, parades and
an ancient evil creature that feeds off of
childrens’ fears -- OK who created this
holiday?
As Mike was marching for the Neibolt Church
Street School band’s annual parade, he noticed
a clown handing out balloons to children on
the side of the road and got a feeling from
the clown that reminded him of the giant bird.
The clown made eye contact and waved at Mike,
as if it had read his mind.
Mike’s trombone went silent as his mouth
dried up at this sight; somehow seeing the
clown felt even worse than seeing Henry Bowers.
Later on up the hill, he came across the clown
again, and wondered how it was possible for
It to have gotten past the marching band that
quickly.
This time, many of the children were crying,
and once again, Pennywise waved to Mike.
This is when he recognized the creature from
Derry’s deep past in his father’s photo
album.
He would share the discovery with his friends
two days later, and the kids would plan
how they could kill It for the first time.
They also start construction on a clubhouse
in the Barrens and the following week, Mike
would bring the photo album along to share
what he knew with the others.
This is basically Mike taking the role of
chief historian of the Losers Club, perhaps
the most important part any of them would
take on as Mike would soon find out.
He shows them Pennywise cameos in pictures
dating back to the early 1700s, then a 1945
photo comes to life and Pennywise terrorizes
them by morphing into it’s many scary forms
like the werewolf, leper, mummy and dead boys.
In late July, the Losers Club decides to try
conducting a smoke hole ceremony, an Indian
ritual used to help tribesmen make big decisions
by breathing in a lot of smoke and having
hallucinations of the best path forward.
Do not try this at home, you’ll just die
or get cancer.
They start a bonfire in the clubhouse and
one-by-one, they jump out when it becomes
too hard to breathe, leaving only Richie and
Mike.
They see the inside of the tiny clubhouse
start to expand, leaving them in a huge space
the size of a ballroom.
Smoke clouds their vision, then they feel
themselves start to float up until Mike realizes
that they are no longer inside of the confines
of the clubhouse, but rather outside in the
Barrens, although these were not the Barrens
as Richie and Mike knew them.
These were the Barrens as they looked millions
of years ago: no standpipe, no houses, but
lots more animal wildlife such as bats, jumping
fish and antelope.
The animals flee the area and they feel as
if they know what’s about to happen, they
can feel the presence of It drawing ever closer.
A burning object pieces through the clouds,
and Mike and Richie run for it.
The next thing they know, they’re being
pulled out of the clubhouse and out of the
hallucination by the others.
Richie passes out, but upon coming back to,
he and Mike tell the story about how they
were able to view the arrival of It, crash
landing from outer-space.
I find it most fitting that it was the group’s
seer and the historian who were there to witness
and pass on the story of this historical event.
The plotting against It continues, throughout
the month.
Mike joins the others in visiting Eddie Kaspbrak
in the hospital after his arm is broken, and
Mike again experiences the dirty prejudices
that corrupt many citizens of Derry when Eddie’s
mom gives him an especially disdainful look
while telling off the six of them.
They go to the Barrens to take turns practicing
with the slingshot to determine who should
be the one to wield it against the monster.
Mike holds the best record by hitting a respectable
5 out of 10 cans until Beverly came and slam
dunked on all of them by hitting each of the
10.
On July 23rd, the silver slugs that Beverly
was to fire at Pennywise were created, and
two days later the seven of them turned up
to 29 Neibolt Street to confront It.
Each of them perceive the house differently
based on their own fears, and for Mike, it
gives him the same vibes he felt at the remains
of the Ironworks where he’d encountered
the giant bird.
The Losers venture upstairs and come across
three doors.
The first contains a mattress that explodes
and oozes out black liquid, so they shut the
door and move onto the second.
When Beverly gets close to it she hears a
scream coming from the other side, and it
has a buzzing quality making it sound like
a giant insect.
Thanks to Mike’s farming expertise due to
many summers working for his father, he’s
able to determine that this is not a monster,
but something known as a “moose blower”,
a can that lets out a constant audible noise
in order to scare crows away from the crops.
The last door contains a dilapidated bathroom
where Beverly is able to use the slingshot
to drive It down into the sewers setting up
the final confrontation of the summer that
would take place a couple weeks later.
On August 10th, Mike is riding his bike through
town and notices a strange lack of activity
and an ominous orange glow setting over the
sky.
One of the only people he bumps into are his
friends, Bill is there with Stan, Richie and
Eddie.
They cross over to the Barrens side of Kansas
Street, where Ben and Beverly run up to them,
going off about how Henry Bowers had come
after her for her life.
Bill determines that Henry and his goons are
being driven by It, and decides it’s time
to go after the monster once more.
They go into The Barrens and rock flies out
of the bushes and strikes Mike in the head.
It had come from Henry, with his goons Belch
and Victor.
The move represents their revenge on Mike
for running to the others and luring the bullies
into the rock fight where they were badly
bombarded with stones.
Mike retaliates by throwing a piece of scrap
wood back at them before the Losers all escape
to the sewers.
The bullies came down into the sewers after
them, and Mike felt trapped between his two
worst demons as he heard Henry’s screams
echoing off the pipes as he continued to pursue
them.
Luckily for him, Henry would not catch up
with for another 27 years, but what awaited
Mike deeper under Derry was worse than he
could have ever imagined.
First, he was restrained by the tentacles
of a giant crawling eye creature that threatened
to crush him where he stood and left him powerless
to fight, it was only Eddie’s heroics that
broke them free.
The eye represented one of Richie’s fears,
but what would come was an incarnation of
something Mike had long been afraid of.
This is another detail that really cements
Mike’s position as the historian and also
sets him apart from any of the others.
When It takes the form of one of their fears,
it’s usually something recent that one of
them saw and frightened them.
For example, Richie sees a werewolf movie
and It becomes a werewolf shortly after to
scare him.
One possible exception is Stan.
The Dead Boys he sees in his solo encounter
with It are from a news bite from many years
ago, however, he only found out about it recently,
so it’s still more of a recent fear.
But the other exception is Mike, whose fear
goes way back to a time he is hardly able
to remember, the bird that attacked him in
his crib as a baby.
The next form It takes is the giant bird,
a form that shows Mike’s eye for all things
past AND present.
The bird dives in and scratches Eddie, and
Mike retaliates by slashing his buck-knife
into It’s talons.
He tries to fight back with the knife again,
but misses and gets cut by the claws.
Luckily, Stan is able to drive to creature
away with his knowledge of birds, likely saving
the lives of Eddie and Mike if not all of
them, and allowing them to continue on into
the lair of It.
After supporting Bill in his interdimensional
mind battle with the monster, Mike and the
others would escape the sewers and vow to
take care of It again if It had somehow survived.
Mike involuntarily takes the position that
they would later refer to as “manning the
lighthouse”, he stayed back in Derry to
keep an eye out for sign of It’s return
over the next 27 years.
Mike was stuck with this because his family
was the only one that did not move away, but
it’s also fitting that he be the one to
stay for two reasons.
First, the others lose their memories of the
events of the summer of 1958 when they leave,
and Mike must retain his memories because
he is and always has been the book keeper,
it’s his responsibility to fill them in
on the history of Derry and the history of
their own quarrels with the monster when they
return.
Second, by staying in Derry, Mike is able
to continue to research Derry’s dark past
and dig out the details necessary to combat
It, should another confrontation be necessary.
Before that happens though, Mike must face
some of the toughest years of his life.
In 1962, when Mike was 15 years old, his father
was hospitalized with cancer.
He would go to visit his dad every day on
his bike, because even four years after the
murders in Derry had ceased, his mother was
still uncomfortable with his trying to hitch
a ride.
During one of these visits, Will told his
son one last story that he had yet to pass
on, the story of the Black Spot fire.
In 1930, during Will’s time in the army,
he helped open up a nightclub that he and
his friends would be welcome at.
The jazz joint became pretty popular, and
white troops started showing up there as well,
until one night an evil organisation set fire
to the place.
After narrowly escaping, Will looked up and
saw the giant bird, not flapping its wings,
but floating with a red balloon tied to each
side.
This event suggests that It has some kind
of generational hold on both Hanlons and gives
Mike the confirmation that the seemingly random
acts of malice may all go back to the monster.
Still, he couldn’t have known if It would
reawaken again, or if he and his friends had
actually killed it in ‘58, so he continued
to keep an eye out.
His father would end up passing away that
year, but he and his Mom would stay in Derry,
and Mike would continue his education at Derry
High School, where he became the running back
of the football team.
The former Losers Club member didn’t achieve
the levels of success his friends did when
they grew up -- something Mike attributes
to their triumph over It leading to success
in other endeavors -- but I think it’s interesting
to note that Mike was able to graduate from
marching band trombonist, to actually being
on the field during the football games.
All of them kind of moved up in the world
after defeating It.
At some point, Mike became the town librarian
and started to conduct deeper research about
the past of Derry.
In 1979, he must have realized that he’d
soon find out if It would be reawakening,
because he subscribed to newspapers in the
six cities his old friends now lived in in
order to keep tabs.
It was around 1980 that he started to sense
that It would in fact come back.
He claims the voice of The Turtle may have
clued him in on this.
Also in 1980, he begins work on a book: Derry,
An Unauthorized Town History by Michael Hanlon.
He starts his research by talking to a former
Derry librarian, a man by the name of Albert
Carson.
Carson discourages him from digging into Derry’s
past, suggesting that the facts that aren’t
recorded in Derry’s history books may disturb
him, but Mike continues to press, so Carson
gives him a couple of leads.
the man who poisoned
his family in 1851, the hacked up lumberjacks
of 1879, and more gruesome details of the
Ironworks explosion that he already knew about.
He also learns there was a man named Branson
Buddinger who tried to write a piece similar
to what Mike is doing, but is essentially
driven mad and died.
Despite this, Mike finds the bravery to continue
researching Derry, and becomes an important
member of the community over the years.
At some point in the 80s, the Aladdin Theater,
where he and the Losers used to spend part
of their summers, is in danger of being shut
down, and Mike helped to call a town meeting
to save it.
Despite the noble act of saving a movie theater,
I think getting involved in the business of
Derry was actually a mistake, but I’ll come
back to why I think that in a little bit.
Mike took note when the murders started up
again in the year 1984, but didn’t want
to call the other Losers back to Derry until
he was absolutely sure that It was back.
He got really close to calling them in February
of 1985 when the disappearances of Dennis
Torio and Lori Anne Winterbarger took place.
Mike started paying off one of the Derry police
officers for more information and copies of
evidence photos for his own documentation.
"Chief's gonna have a cow when he sees you nosing around Mike."
"I won't tell him if you don't."
In March, he stays late at the library one
night and finds a balloon tied to his reading
lamp with a photo of him attached.
One drunken night in April, Mike reads about
Claude Heroux and the crimes he committed
in 1905.
That night, he also gets the sense that It
wants revenge for when the Losers nearly killed
it as kids.
Mike keeps on documenting the incidents that
take place through May 22, when a 5th grader
named Jerry Bellwood is found alongside the
words Come Home printed on a cement wall in
blood.
That ends up being the final straw before
Mike calls his six childhood friends back
to Derry.
He sets up a reunion lunch near the recently
built mall at a Chinese place called Jade
of the Orient.
His reasoning for choosing it, is that it’s
new, and he probably know better than anyone
that It has a stranglehold on everything from
Derry’s past.
Only five of them make it to the reunion,
and Mike has to explain how Stan had passed
away.
He fills them in on everything, I just said
in the last 4-5 minutes of this video that
I don’t care to repeat.
As the Losers spend more time back in Derry,
their childhood scars start to come back,
and Mike reveals claw scars on his chest,
he would have acquired against the giant bird
in the sewers 27 years ago.
Things start to get weird when they all get
their fortune cookies, but they try to play
it cool when the waitress comes by as not
to raise alarm.
“So who do you think’s going to win the
pennant?”
Bill asked Mike, smiling insanely.
Rose came through the curtain just then, her
face politely questioning.
“I think the Chicago Bears look good,”
Mike said.
If only he had seen them on Monday Night Football
this week against Washington!
Khalil Mack!
Danny Travathan!
Ha-Ha Clinton Pick Six!
No, but the book takes place in 1985, which
of course is the year that The Bears won the
Super Bowl.
The movie, It Chapter 2, takes place in 2016,
so it would have been an excellent opportunity
to do that same scene but with a different
answer.
“So who do you think’s going to win the
pennant?”
“I think the Chicago Cubs look good.”
Anyway, where even was I?
Right.
Mike Hanlon.
They all go their separate ways and plan to
meet at the library later, and during this
down time, Mike gets a call from Bill, asking
if he can store a bike he just bought in Mike’s
shed, and Mike somehow knows right away that
it’s Bill’s old bike, Silver, and says
yes.
They fix up the bike together with a patch
kit Mike bought a week beforehand on an impulse,
even though he doesn’t even own a bike.
This is more evidence that there was a “helping
hand” at play this time, just as the Turtle
helped them in 1958, there was a different
hand of fate guiding them as adults.
Now when Mike joined the group after the rock
fight 27 years ago, he felt himself become
the final piece.
The wheel was complete, and it could begin
to roll, and that’s when they started making
plans to fight Pennywise.
The reason Mike had them all walk around town
and regain their memories was to see if they
could close that wheel again, it would be
smaller without Stan, but it was the only
chance they had to defeat It, but that evening
Mike’s plan would go horribly wrong.
It was 1:15AM after another meeting with the
Losers at the Derry Public Library when Mike
advised them all to go back to the hotel and
get some sleep.
He decided to stay a bit longer and log the
night’s events in his journal, but he had
a strange feeling he wasn’t alone in the
library.
Fifteen minutes later he hears a footstep,
and approaches with a letter opener as his
only defense.
It was his old enemy, Henry Bowers, freed
from the mental asylum he’d been locked
up in by It.
Henry has his old blade back as well, and
the two go at it.
It eggs Henry on by taking the form of Stan’s
head and then later Belch’s head on the
library circulation desk and telling him to
finish Mike off.
Ultimately, Mike’s letter opener is enough
to fend him off though, and Henry flees the
library thinking that Mike had lost enough
blood to do him in, but pretty badly injured
himself.
Mike is barely able to make it to the phone
to call 911.
Pennywise messes with him in the process,
by taking over the telephone line Mike is
trying to talk on and replacing the clock
face with the face of Will Hanlon.
Police find Mike barely hanging on when they
arrive and transfer him to the hospital, where
It would make one more attempt on his life.
The other five decided that the longer they
waited to take on It, the more danger they
were putting themselves in.
For a long time, it seemed strange to me that
the novel is told from Mike’s perspective
more than anyone else's, but he isn’t there
for the final confrontation, but on further
examination, I think that’s exactly the
reason that he couldn’t be there for the
final fight.
Remember earlier, when I mentioned Mike getting
involved in the community to save the theater?
I think he basically acclimated himself into
Derry.
He stayed there and became a part of the town,
and as we know, Pennywise rules all things
Derry.
He may have had good intentions, but he was
really no more capable of stopping It than
characters like Mr. Nell and Mr. Gedreau.
Mike stays the night in the hospital and over
the next four hours, a huge storm brews above
Derry as his friends make their way towards
the lair of It.
At 6:46AM, Mike awakens with a bad feeling.
It has possessed one of the nurses at the
hospital, Marc Lemonica, the brother of one
of the victims, who was taken by It in 1958.
He’s planning on overdosing Mike with a
loaded syringe, and Mike doesn’t have the
physical strength to stop him.
At that moment, Bill and the others sense
Mike is in danger.
They join hands and telekinetically send some
of their power to him, and instance of the
Losers Club using The Shine to aid their friend,
but for some reason when the Losers sense
Mike is in danger it always reminds me more
of the destruction of Alderaan in Star Wars.
“Are you alright?
What’s wrong?”
“I felt a great disturbance in the Force.
As if millions of voices suddenly cried out
in terror.
And were suddenly silenced.”
Maybe we could draw some comparisons to the
abilities held by the characters in King’s
writing and “the Force”, but that sounds
like a fan-fiction for another day.
The power from his friends gives Mike the
ability to pick up a bottle and crack it over
Lamonica’s head.
Bill and Richie had the strength to continue
on and defeat Pennywise knowing their friend
Mike would be OK.
Mike ended up spending the week in the hospital.
On June 4th, Bill dropped by to bring him
his manuscript and he offered up his place
to Bill and his wife, who was trying to recover
from her encounter with It’s deadlights.
They are all starting to lose their memories
again, but this time, Mike is losing his as
well, because with Pennywise dead, there is
no reason he needs to hold onto that trauma
any longer.
He also feels that with It gone, Derry is
dying as well, which ties in nicely to my
theory about Mike not joining in on the final
battle because he had become an integral part
of Derry.
By June 11th, the day Mike was discharged
from the hospital, he had nearly completely
forgotten everything about his group of friends
from 1958.
He tried writing everything down, the only
logical approach he could take being the group’s
record keeper, but the words faded from the
pages hours after he wrote them.
Mike has grown tired of Derry and likely moves
on from It after the end of the novel, with
him no longer needing to keep watch.
But before he leaves, he makes one final dedication
to the town he spent so much of his life in.
He commissions a memorial plaque at the site
the standpipe once stood before it was swept
away in the terrible storm.
TO THOSE LOST IN THE STORM.
MAY 31, 1985.
And to the children.
All the children.
Love Bill, Ben, Bev, Eddie, Richie, Stan,
Mike.
The Losers Club.
Even after moving onto a new life and finally
forgetting about the best friends of his childhood,
he would sometimes still encounter them in
his dreams.
If you want to hear my analysis of the
other members of the Losers Club click that
playlist on the left.
And there are a couple more coming soon so
if you don’t want to miss out on those make
sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.